more fighting in Northeast Syria between
Kurds and Turkish backed Syrian rebels
in videos uploaded by Kurdish fighters
they say they're defending their
positions outside the so called safe
zone south of the towns of Columbia in
Russia line fighters who formed a
coalition called the Syrian National
Army or SNA deny they're making any
territorial gains there he says five
soldiers were wounded in attacks by
Kurdish fighters who are reportedly
being backed by Syrian government forces
although no one has claimed
responsibility Turkish military sources
accused the Kurds of carrying out four
bombings in the last four days within
the safe zone the fighting is happening
despite an agreement for a six day pause
forces loyal to Syria's President Bashar
al-assad have moved into towns and
villages outside of the 30 kilometer
boundary agreed by Russia and Turkey and
Russian military police as well as
soldiers from Chechnya are patrolling
areas under Kurdish control they're
implementing the patrol agreement under
which the Kurds will leave their
positions inside the safe zone Turkey is
a NATO member and its dealings with
Russia in Syria have not been welcomed
by many of its Western Allies before
arriving in Ankara Germany's foreign
minister called Turkey's offensive
against the Kurds and invasion we were
told the proposal on creating an
international safe zone is not a
realistic suggestion that's why we use
the time to deal with those issues which
are important for the people in Syria
right now the issue of what happens with
the ceasefire after 150 hours and the
issue of how humanitarian aid continues
with those who are fleeing in Syria the
invasion comment outraged turkeys
leaders they say European allies don't
share the burden of refugees and refused
to support turkeys operation against PKK
fighters were designated a terrorist
group by the European Union
apart from bilateral issues we found
this a good opportunity to talk about
the Syrian issue as a whole I also
focused on the fact that the US and
Russia have recognized the developments
in the field without peace spring
operation there are so many aims of that
operation one of them is to return the
Syrian refugees we need to clean this
area from the terrorist organizations
turkey says it's safe zone is meant to
create a space for refugees to return
but more people have been displaced
since turkey began its military
operation in northern Syria almost three
weeks ago the World Food Programme says
a hundred and seventy-six thousand
people have so far fled the fighting a
plane was bombing and we barely managed
to escape to save ourselves and our
children they provided some mattresses
blankets and food but we have no doors
no windows this is how we are living 150
our agreement between Turkey and Russia
expires on Tuesday the US president says
he expects a permanent ceasefire and has
warned of reimposing economic sanctions
on Turkey
if ceasefire violations take place but
Turkish president is adamant that he
wants to establish this 30 kilometre
deep zone inside Syria to repatriate
more than three million Syrian refugees
with or without the support of his
allies sama bin Javed al Jazeera a truck
lay on the turkey-syria border